from the new one so i'm broadcasting now
live and i'm broadcasting live so wait
wait wait
maybe i can hear you guys broadcasting
right now
so you should have the link somehow
a
we're good we're good okay
so so i'm sorry guys
um there's been a few technical problems
uh here um so guys sorry i'm talking to
my team
uh i think we can you know we can start
the live so i'm going to turn off turn
off skype just in
i'm sorry turn off uh what's up
i think we can start uh sorry guys
you know technical problems that happens
kevin berta i'll see you later okay
so just gonna turn this off
okay sorry um nope as i say no pressure
but uh you know technical problems i
think
we have learned a lesson or two about
setting things
uh i mean we've done it before three
four times this is the fourth time but
today it didn't work properly but that's
fine uh
better late than never as they say so
um so let's get started
i have a lot of you know a lot of
messages coming through let me go up
first of all so lara i'm glad to hear
that now you can hear me
so um let's get started without further
ado this this live
uh so i'm going to start with a couple
of these questions and then i'm going to
go through the
some of the questions that you have
you're asking me here
um the very first question that i got
was from edward
wolff and he asked is it useful to learn
the phonetic
notation of the ipa the international
phonetic alphabet
to master the pronunciation rules of the
of your target language is there a
better way to get
to know the pronunciation details of
your target language
and my answer is there is no need
to study the the ipa the international
international phonetic alphabet is
as as far as i'm concerned i've never
really used it
it helped me a little bit you know when
i was looking
specifically for some sounds but in
general
edward if if you want to do something
for your pronunciation first of all get
started
from the very beginning and then i think
you should
learn to listen actively so to look for
details to notice things to ask
uh for example native speakers to
correct you to point out your mistakes
because
it's impossible for uh for a non-native
to understand all the nuances
of the phonetic system of a language so
it's important to get interested get
started from the very beginning
listen attentively notice the details
and ask
for feedback as much as you can listen
and read at the same time because this
is a very powerful weapon
that you have in order to dissect
so to speak the the phonetic fabric of a
language i think that
we should imitate kids in a way you
should listen a lot but
listen with with attention notice in the
details because listening
and just massively listening is not
enough unfortunately so we need a little
bit of
this so-called deliberate practice in
order to work our pronunciation
and this is what i do i do listen a lot
but i also notice the details and i'm
very
open to corrections so one important
thing
is more than the ipa i think is be open
to corrections
and listen to what people tell you you
know when they give you feedback
sometimes we get a little bit offended
if someone corrects us
and we disregard some of the help that
some people give us but it's very
important
and another thing that has been um
really useful
um for me for example when it comes to
the
uh the infamous d the dane of the danish
pronunciation
of the danish language i spent a couple
of
hours actually dissecting the sound by
the thing that was the most helpful for
me was actually to watch a couple of
videos especially one video in
particular of a guy
who explained this how the d works in
context not only the
pronunciation of the single you know of
the d in words but also how you
pronounce entire sentences
that more than anything helped me i
tried before to look
at how the sound the sound specifically
works
with ipa very lengthy descriptions in
the ipa but
they didn't do me any good and when i
finally got to
hear how the d is actually used it made
a whole
world of difference so that's the first
uh that's the first
answer now i'm going to ask reply to
some of the the questions here
uh how do you keep a lot of languages in
your mind i'm going to go a little bit
uh not not fast but i you know i'll try
to answer as many
uh questions as possible so i won't
spend
too much time i'm gonna try to go
straight to the point so
uh i think i answered this question
multiple times but to make a long story
short i have designed a life where i get
to use
let's say during the week between five
languages
and eight on a good day i would even go
i would even
use ten languages and either because i
use it a work
or because i use it at home or i use it
in a number of circumstances i read a
lot so
um if you know there's a mechanism in
your brain which is called survival of
the busiest if you keep using
languages well you don't get rusty
inevitably though since i
i'm managing 14 languages two or three
languages i i don't speak them very
often and they get rusty inevitably but
it's not the end of the world
so okay have sound fantastic sounds
great finally saludos i can hear you
what happened
technical problems uh so greetings here
uh so rita
what do you do to learn languages that
are very close to your first language or
to a language you speak very well in
portuguese
i'm a portuguese native speaker and
wanted to learn italian or spanish
things in that case i was talking about
it with a student of mine yesterday
during a lesson and
what i normally do when it comes to
languages that are very similar
is that i still use my bi-directional
translation method
but i get to speak from the almost from
the get-go from the very beginning so
in if you want to learn a language like
spanish or italian my advice is to get
a good piece of content uh to start with
it's always great to have a great
you know language learning material to
start with it can be anything it can be
you know i have assimil but you can use
anything that you like on the market
but on top of that i would start talking
to someone
on on skype or on the internet you can
find a teacher or you can find a
friendly person to talk to when you talk
to them
maybe once a week or twice a week and
you would be amazed to see
how fast you can actually speak a
language that is very similar because
fundamentally the the huge load off is
that
since the vocabulary is very similar and
the structure is very similar it's not
really difficult to formulate to form
sentences
it's more about acquiring vocabulary and
the easier
the the sooner you start the better in
this case if you're
learning a language that is quite
distant from
your native language or a language you
have under your belt
i wouldn't go for that strategy but in
general if a language is similar
um you know like portuguese for example
i didn't speak for a long time actually
did a very
input based approach but then i figured
out i could have might as well have
spoken directly from the you know after
a couple of
so uh
let me see here no problem my question
oops
now i have to go up because all the
questions have been piling up
so let me see uh hi luca greetings from
romania greetings from rome
uh can you tell us about your future
books i'm looking forward to reading it
books yes i have actually books in mind
but i'm seriously contemplating the idea
of writing one specific book i've been
talking about it for a long time
um now i'm actually more focusing
on creating online courses and
you will see there's there's a surprise
coming you in
within the next weeks the next few weeks
so stay tuned
about that uh but the book
actually was one of the big projects
this year so we're actually thinking
whether to
to get it out there this year to get it
out there next year but it's going to
happen
and i don't want to promise things that
don't deliver my promises but
i think it's about time to get a book
out people have been asking me about it
so
uh i'm going to write a book and uh it's
it's going to happen
and i will let you know when the moment
comes
so i took a phonetics class in school
because i'm
in speech pathology i feel the same way
helped a bit with sounds in portuguese i
didn't know how to produce but i don't
think it's necessary
you were talking probably about the ipa
i think it's always
great to work on sounds it's not
actually as difficult as it looks you
know we don't get
we don't get a lot of uh instructions
about that at school at least as far as
i'm concerned in italy that didn't
happen
and this action this pronunciation thing
is a little bit disregarded and they
when when you ask someone hey how do you
how do you improve your pronunciation
you know they answer just listen just
listen and repeat and you're going to
find it's a little bit of a simplistic
answer i think
because if you actually understand how
to tackle sounds then
you can learn you can learn a language
and you can acquire very good
pronunciation anybody can so
i think it's a stereotype and it's it's
a falsehood
falsehood that you can not actually
speak a language well stephen crashing
uh talks about that in a pdf that you
can find online which is a conjecture
about
uh you know about learning accent and a
second language or something along those
lines kevin
uh kevin can put um you know a link
in the in the chat so
um you need to close the other live
people are still there
i think kevin is going to take care of
that guys like i
i think i yeah you're right actually
let me s no i i don't want to touch
anything guys honestly
because now i'm streaming live in two
places
i guess but uh there's nobody there so
if i touch anything
then you know something could happen so
i'm just gonna leave it there gonna you
know
broadcast from two places that's fine
what's the best way to learn vocabulary
i think i've talked about that kevin you
can
you can please um you know leave
a couple of links to articles and
youtube videos that i've made
specifically about vocabulary
uh it's a it's a broad question so it's
complex to tackle here i've tackled it
before
uh but fundamentally if i can give you
one piece of advice when it comes to
learning vocabulary is to get a massive
exposure and to make sure that you have
a system to
let's say get catch words
and put them in places where you're
going to review them it can be like a
notebook or you can be an app
this is what i would do if you want to
use apps like anki or
other apps that you know help you retain
vocabulary that's great but as far as
i'm concerned in my experience
the more exposure you get and also if
you
pay attention to the details if you have
a system to kill or do
do you spread them uh throughout the
week
this is a very interesting question um
and i would like to point out
um a book that talks about that talks
about this and many things
if you guys have never
first of all if you like books reading
can
can change your mind your world your
existence i love reading as you can
imagine this is a book that has
helped me figure out a lot of things you
know it's called
it's i think one of the best books about
learning in general how we learn and why
it happens with benedict carey
kevin will link with will leave a link
in the description box
and they specifically talk about
interleaving so to answer your question
anita interleaving is this kind of thing
that helps you
like vary your activities every day and
what i normally do
is i organize things so that i can get
i can listen and read every single day
that's the base let's
imagine that you're you're learning
activities are like a pyramid so
uh the base the is always exposure to
language i listen and read
read and listen to interesting stuff
every day if i can give you a very
uh specific and concrete example with
greek i am
every single day i watch a video
and i take notes but then i also do
different things every single day for
example one day i can
read some some notes i can take some
notes and transfer them into my
my notebooks another day these are all
techniques i'm not getting into the
details but these are all techniques
that
you know i i use i talk to myself by
using some notes
another day i'm talking to my tutor
another day i'm reading a wikipedia
article
on top of on top of the the youtube
video so the youtube video is the base
then you have different activities like
talking to myself talking to my tutor
uh reading a wikipedia article and
many other things so you should have a
base and then you should
make sure that on a weekly basis you
have a cycle where
you tackle possibly all areas of
language writing listening reading
speaking or writing
on a weekly basis this does not mean
that you have to take one hour
if you have one hour of your time let's
say time t right an interval of time
it has to be one quarter for each
activity
not every day you just need to have a
base and then you can vary along
a week because if you do that you're
telling your brain that all these areas
are
interesting and and important and
they're usually going to reinforce each
other
hello from france hello from rome um
so okay i mean thank you for your
patience with the technical difficulties
thanks thanks guys again it's amazing to
see that there's uh 255 people
still here they haven't you haven't
abandoned us
um what do you think about matt versus
japan approach daniel farias
asked me um and nicole in which
languages do you have a certification
let me ask the second one and then the
and then the you know the first no the
second one and then the first
um so basically um
i have four certifications i think i
have them somewhere
uh i don't know where they are now but
they're in english
spanish french and german and they're
basically c2
all c2 at the c2 level and i did them
some 10 years ago
now i would really like to do the i
sorry guys i don't have it here the uh
the polish one for c1 and the the one
for russian c1
so and then and then let's see what
happens uh
as far as um um japan
versus matt or matt versus japan i had
the pleasure of talking to matt
a few months ago we we did a couple of
interviews together
i gotta confess that i don't know
exactly what he does i know that this is
an input-based approach
and that he was also following
uh ajax right so uh all japanese all
time
according to whom it's important to if i
understood correctly surround yourself
with the language as much as you can
i would say it's a sound um it's a
reasonable
you know strategy if you want to learn
the language the more you expose
yourself to it
the the better it is but then you have
to just
think about the the amount of time that
you want to spend if you are
free and if you have all the time and
all the energy
in the world to invest in a language the
more the merrier the more the better
so i think it totally makes sense to
expose yourself
the language and to pay attention i
really like what i really like about
matt is that he's very meticulous about
his approach to understand you know he
wrote for example
a very interesting article about pitch
accent and i think that if you do care
about pitch accent if you do care about
some aspects of the phonetic structure
of a language or
a grammar of a language or what what
have you
then um then it's great uh you know it's
uh i think it makes a it makes a huge
difference
uh when it comes to uh you know
speaking language well so i i think he
definitely has
a valuable approach and the proof is in
the pudding as they say because he
speaks
japanese at a native like level and i
think that when you listen to someone's
advice
look at the results you know i think
that's important
and um what do you think about
math versus japan have done that um so
let me check i'd like to know if you
think that learning chinese writing is
relevant for my chinese i love reading
chinese
characters but i'm not planning to take
an hsk which is uh the typica
you know the standard um the standard
exam
thanks for your answer daniele prosper
and danielle your time for sure
so um i would say
it depends it depends on what you want
to achieve i think
when it comes to learning a language
especially when it comes to learning
languages like chinese or japanese you
have to ask yourself what do i want to
do with the language
so i've noticed that a few people have
asked me when i tell them for example i
that i speak japanese and chinese that
the first question
not the first question but one of the
most common questions is how many
characters do you know
and my answer is always doesn't matter
so
to me it's much more important to be
able to speak the language rather than
how many characters i know and i think
you learn characters from the language
and not the other way around
and having said that if you're
interested in knowing characters and you
want to write
and if you want to work on your
calligraphy
if you have a specific goal and if you
like characters then by all means go for
it but if your
if your goal is to speak the language i
what i've done personally is to expose
myself to the language so i got assimil
and then i got other resources i've been
listening and reading a ton
i've been speaking i've been using the
language i've been typing in chinese
through the software programs that you
have and i've been learning to recognize
characters without being able to
i can write a couple of them
but i can recognize a lot of them so you
have to ask yourself
does it matter to you if you want to
speak the language i would
you know focus on speaking the language
getting to know
uh people getting to know the culture
watching a lot of stuff
and then on top of that if you want to
do specific exercises to learn
uh characters i think that's great so i
this is how i would do things but again
for me
chinese characters are an important part
of the language in the culture but
they're not the main focus
so um let me see here
and let me see top three points for
learning dutch i think
learning dutch is like like top three
tips i would say to learn anything
i think you have to know exactly why you
want to learn you by experimenting again
i always i'm big on methods but i'm
bigger i'm bigger on principles meaning
that if you work every day if you do it
for a long period of time if you're
motivated and if you experiment and find
the you know the way of learning
languages that suits your needs and
and taste then then bingo it's gonna
happen for sure and this doesn't only go
for dutch it goes for any other language
so um have you read any literature in
the
olga have you ever read any literature
in danish swedish and norwegian if so
do you have any favorite scandinavian
authors that you have read in the
original languages
i'm impressed by your speech talk to me
olga
i think i have just if you give me a
second i think i have a few
i have uh i recently bought
um um
camila berry i don't know if you guys
have ever heard of camila leckberry
i really like how she writes i have
here i don't know if you can see it's a
big book this is a trilogy of
uh sht larson like i guess you guys have
heard about stickler
and i i i write these books then i
really like
kepler so there's like this scandinavian
literature recently i was desperately
looking for
a way to buy these books online that are
a cheap way seems like it's difficult
but i bought all the stuff and was in
sweden
so yes i i read a lot of books in
popular music from victor there's also
another one by finnish
author and i have them all there now i
can't get them here
because it's going to get complicated
but yes i i do
i do love swedish literature i even
bought all these books in portuguese
uh when i was in portugal by stiglar so
i have it in a couple of versions and i
have some of these books for example
it you know by stephen king i like it so
much that i bought in like
seven languages the most recent version
is polish that i i bought it directly on
amazon now you have amazon in poland as
well you didn't have it before
um placation
hi luca has there ever been has there
ever been a language that you have
really struggled with
yes it's japanese and i've made an
entire video about it and the reason why
i struggle with it was
wasn't is because i had the wrong
approach and i can't wait to go back to
it but now i'm more focusing on greek
and hungarian and i'm danish and then in
2022 if
uh chances arise i will go back to
mandarin chinese and especially i'm
excited especially excited about
japanese going back to
japanese because i think it's an amazing
language and um
and i i want to go back to it so
uh ernie says i tried learning to this
is not a question
more like a statement i tried learning
two languages at the same time i didn't
like how it took my time away from one
one at a time is better this has been my
experience so
focusing on one at the time now i'm
focusing on three but it's really
difficult
i think in a couple weeks if we're lucky
um
technical problems aside we'll i'll
start republishing
longer videos uh in on thursdays and one
of them
is about my struggle learning three
languages actively
learning three languages at the same
time i think one is better but
uh now i'm learning three so we'll see
what happens
um so along
jamie sorry guys for pushing your names
hey luca i'm currently learning french
and i'm hoping to reach a conversation
level in a month or two
after that i wanted to try my hand
either spanish or italian so which one
do you suggest
i can't really suggest anything for you
because it depends on you i i don't
think you should
you should just choose uh you know
flipping a coin
you should just choose based on what
interest you make maybe you can just
delve into
you know the culture a little bit more
read a little bit more about the
countries or if you
know some people and i think choosing a
language is an important thing
if you want to do it seriously so just
flipping a coin saying oh spanish or
italian spanish or time
might not be the most appropriate way to
go you might give it a little more
more thought before you make a decision
and the other thing i would say is that
if you're learning french i would
highly recommend that you get it to a
nice level let's say you get at least to
a conversational level before you start
spanish or italian because then two
languages can actually conflict
if you do not learn um
the previous one relatively well
because if you're learning relatively
well or you get a decent level actually
you can leverage that knowledge to learn
another language which is very similar
so something that can be you know a
problem can actually turn
into an opportunity so
um
along i know it sounds a bit early to be
thinking about another language but i
don't know how often you do these live
streams so i wanted to make this one
count
love your channel by the way thanks uh
thanks a lot thanks so much
i do it every month so at the end of
every month
uh i did the last sunday of every month
i'm just going to do a live the only
thing is that i'm going to be traveling
i'm going to munich
germany and then i'm going to be in
poland for a couple of months
so um you know keep that in mind i might
skip one but basically i will
start doing them regularly every month
the only thing is that we're probably
moving to another language
english is great we're going to do
another one in english and then we're
going to
start giving live sessions in spanish
that's going to be the next language as
much as and i this was a request
to do this in multiple languages it's
really difficult because
if i speak a language for five minutes
that some other people don't understand
i'm gonna lose
some of the audience so english is the
obvious choice but
we want to start doing uh some live
streams in spanish and then possibly in
italian and then we'll see
so uh i'm learning dalville says i'm
learning italian and looking for
documentary resources i would very very
highly recommend super quark
it's called super quark you write super
quark italiano
and you you have loads of interesting
content and on
on youtube and another and on the net
this is one of my favorite pro
you know uh programs uh as far as
italian is concerned and documentaries
uh is concerned so
spencer hydrogen advance in spanish but
i still struggle to understand the plot
of new spanish movies better to watch
the same movie over and over or continue
fighting through new movies
interesting um i would uh
if i were you i would do the following
this is something that i recommend to my
students
download for example if you're watching
net if you're using netflix
or if you have the possibility of you
know for example
downloading subtitles especially netflix
you can use a
chrome extension which is called learn
languages with netflix
and what you can do is you can click
yeah i have a video on that so go and
look
learn languages with netflix on youtube
and you will see the instructions
you can actually create a bi-lingual
script of the entire movie
and you can i know that this sounds
weird but if you're if you're watching
movies to learn the language you might
want to look at the script before you
watch the movie
and you can highlight certain parts and
it's really easy to understand the
content by using a bilingual structure
and then you can watch the movie
so in that case it's so much easier to
understand the content of the movie
i would say variety quality and quantity
so i would watch
a lot of movies and i but also i would
start approaching them in a meticulous
analytical way so that you can dissect
the content better because just watching
the
a lot of movies understanding 20 of them
or even less
might not be the best way to go about
them you can spend a little bit of time
dissecting
you know movies in this way and then
the more you expose yourself to the
language the more you're going to
understand the easier it is going to be
to enjoy
and watch movies in general so
my channel how luca how are you i'm a
little bit dehydrated so i'll have to
grab a cup
of a little bit of water in a second but
apart from that i'm great the weather is
getting better and better here in rome
um i love your channel greetings from
brazil
here in southern brazil we speak
thailand or brazilian
venice or brazilian very interesting i
heard in brazil you have
a lot of people from japanese origin
from italian origin there's a
amazing melting pot and i even recently
watched a documentary about
some kind of german dialect spoken in
the in the
you know in the heart of brazil which is
really interesting um
i don't know there's a lot of consonants
there yes languages can rust to my
german is so rusty it's not
it's totally normal that you know
everybody's languages go rusty if you
don't use them
um so
i have been speaking still la marina i
think stella mining has seen your name
before
rings a bell i've been speaking english
for a year by now but it still feels
stuck
sometimes as the f as is
the difficult sentences don't want to
come out from my mouth some advice to
unstop my poor fluency
well as tried as it may sound i would
just
speak i would just speak to yourself and
i will speak to
some people the most obvious choice is
to talk to someone
if you can get a hold of someone you can
talk to that'd be great but you can also
talk to yourself
there are it's not crazy to talk to
yourself in a foreign language i do it
all the time i am enjoying doing this
every single morning
with greek i love it i love every second
of it i have a strategy to talk to
myself of course
it's not just i wake up and i talk to
myself going around
but i think that that's one thing that
you can do
if you don't have anybody to talk to to
get unstuck
and when it comes to a specific skill
like speaking you have to speak either
you talk to yourself or you talk to
uh you talk to someone or you can start
sending messages on
on what's up or what's up or whatever i
use all these three
for example i i talk to myself
i talked to someone once a week and also
started every single day being very
um you know meticulous about
sending vocal messages uh that i think
about before so that i can
expand a little bit my vocabulary i'd
look some words up and then i send
messages
practice makes perfect so
i've been learning russian ash ashaman
i've been learning russian for about a
year and i'd like to know how my level
compares to others who have been
learning for one year how could i do
this i don't
i ashman honestly i don't think it's
worth it i don't think you should
compare
yourself with others i think you should
compare yourself
you should compare your level that you
have today with the level you had
yesterday
for with the level you had two months
ago i don't think that comparing
yourself with others
is going to help you because everyone is
different and there's people who learn
faster
or more slowly depending on their life
circumstances a number and
myriad other factors that are difficult
to um you know to take into account and
to
to visualize and i i think it's
you we should never compare we have the
tendency of comparing ourselves with
others
but i don't think we should you should
compare yourself you should ask yourself
am i the better version of myself today
than i was like two months ago this is
the question you should ask yourself
maybe not every day but every week or
every month
so um do you have any tips on learning
grammar cases
cough i'm coughing myself too because i
have to cough
so um i'm learning finnish jonas i think
we have
we we i have a specific video about that
and i have
an article about that and kevin can
gently you know can gently provide the
link where i talk about how to learn
cases but basically the
the piece of advice that the the bottom
line is
to expose yourself to the language make
sure that you use some colors if you
want color coding you can
highlight some some cases but i think
that when it comes to
learning grammar patterns and cases is
definitely an interesting feature a
grammatical feature
you should make sure that you get to
learn cases naturally instead of using
tables that are just going to slow you
down
but please take a look at the watch the
video
and read the article you can even listen
to the article there's a lot of
a lot of information there for you to
uh to enjoy so i wanted to read another
question that i
uh jot it down here i printed this text
that was asked on
i think instagram and
[Music]
there's a recurring question have you
ever been interested in learning sign
language and i
have never i
i met one of my students she's a sign
language interpreter we talked about
that very interesting
stuff i've never thought about learning
that but if the you know the possibility
arises why not i think it's very
interesting
and i i i got to know that i know that
sign language every every country has
its own system that's fascinating i
thought since they're using gestures
you can use the same language it's the
the the
quintessential universal language it and
it's it's
no it's not the way it works you have to
learn a different system
for every country what was the most
difficult challenge as a coach
that you've ever faced most difficult
challenge
as a coach that you have ever faced
that's interesting
i would say unmotivated students if you
find someone who doesn't
who just figured out that they don't
want to learn the language that's the
biggest uh the biggest
you know challenge but as i always say
they're not
there are always solutions to problems
so whenever a problem arises i see
myself as a problem solver we talk about
it
with my students and then we find a
solution and then if they want to walk
the
you know talk and walk the path then
that's great if they don't
if they are not motivated there's not
much i can do
unless you know i find ways to motivate
them but generally
uh i think that's that's the main
challenge to you know when you find
someone who's not motivated but i have
to confess that this hasn't happened
recently because i think 99 of my
students are very motivated they come to
me
and they say i'm paying you and i am
very motivated
and they have we you know they have a
goal of mine they want to learn a
language for me and we go like hey
this is what you're going to do they do
it and you know it's amazing what
happens in a matter of months so i'm
very proud that i can
you know deliver the service and then i
can help as many people as i can
and soon we're going to be able to help
even more
um so te gustaria prendereo
if i like if i would like to learn
hebrew yes i got
myself a book and i definitely like to
learn hebrew
so uh let me go down here to
the last questions on at the bottom
so so let me see
so cualizono adri qualisono
emiori materialeso
pero this is interesting what are the
the most the best what is the best
material to learn
russian for a native spanish speaker i
think casimil
i think if asimo has russian spanish i
think you should definitely go for
uh for that and then there's also i
don't know if you guys ever heard of
russian podcasts
uh it's russianpodcast.eu
you know she has the author she has a
fantastic
uh the owner of the website she has a
fantastic
website collection of of videos of
uh bilingual articles i think if you
have an
a1 you you you can learn the basics of
russian through asimil and then you can
you know you have a couple of amazing
russian
resources if you go to
lucalampanella.com if you go to the
resources session i have
listed a number of resources for russia
and we're going to add
other resources and very interesting
youtube youtube channels
talking about you know addressing
science history etc so
uh i think that asimo is great for
native italian speakers
native spanish speakers and you know in
general
if you can speak uh one of the languages
that they provide
uh like for example i didn't have it
here
let me see if i have it i can't see it
right now
damn today's a disaster between
technical problems
and my impossibility physical
impossibility to find books
uh well anyway russian has i have i
wanted to show you this this is russian
in italian unfortunately
asimo sometimes does not have uh the
version in english which makes it a
little bit difficult for native english
speakers or for people who speak only
english
who want to rely on i don't know
english or french so it's difficult for
example
to learn some languages with asimo
because unfortunately they
only have some versions in say french if
you don't speak french
like thai for example thai only has a
french version because asimo originally
is a french company
so probably they realized that there's
not a lot of market for thai
for native english speakers and then
they just provided it in french
so
michael grebin i'm an english teacher
i'm an english teacher i use
english all the time i even passed a c2
exam but i'm still
not native like how do i make myself
think
and speak like a native that's a tough
that's a tough one michael i made a
video about
uh the difference between native speaker
or native like let's say native like
level and c2
and in order and my answer to that is
that in order to s
to to think and speak like a native you
have to spend an
awful amount of time in the in country
you have to do where you live how you
live you have to spend a lot of time
in the environment possibly within
with a you know within a family and then
and then you should pay attention to all
the details
so in short it's a complicated thing
guys i'm just going to grab a glass of
water because i'm just thirsty just give
me a second
okay i'm back so
to answer your question it's a difficult
thing to pull off
and it requires a lot of time and very
specific circumstances but the question
michael is does it matter
to speak like a native what's what's the
point of that
unless you have a very very specific
goal with that i don't i don't
i don't think um i don't think it's a
it's a goal that is realistic
for most people not to sound
discouraging
um
secret jacobsen hi luca you often talk
about citing a date for starting and
developing daily habits
what do you think about learning in a
more unstructured and pleasured way
based way if that fits your personality
that's great siege
if you want to go for that i think you
should
i always think that it depends on your
goals if you want to learn a language
you can't if you want to learn a
language and you want to speak well
if you expose yourself to language doing
stuff you like it's going to happen
it all depends on your goals if you want
to speak it eloquently
with precision and then it's a different
matter you have to put in some
some deliberate work so to speak but if
you want to learn a language
for your own pleasure i think it's great
you can do whatever whatever floats your
boat if you
you don't have to be structured you want
to listen to something then the other
day do a little bit of duolingo
uh whatever whatever it's it's great i
i'm not
i'm not against it at all i'm just
saying that if you have a structured
approach
and if you are deliberate about certain
things you can
actually curate you can you can refine
some aspects of your language
then you know approaching stuff with a
specific aim
any activity is going to make a big
difference
an example of that is netflix you
there's you can go
and and uh watch a movie on netflix
or a show whatever it is uh just by
watching and enjoying it
or you can approach it with a more
systematic way where you
you watch it but you also uh you know
either use
the chrome extension and you make sure
that you mark some words or you
jot them down uh it depends on you i did
both
depending on the level and the goals
that i had
you know so there's nothing wrong in
enjoying the language without having a
systematic approach
so
[Applause]
jj do you have any suggestions for
someone trying to learn
by by himself or herself ancient
languages like old greek
latin and old english my suggestion
would be again now i
wanted to find the book for um for the
latin
for i can't find it right now
yeah because i actually recently moved
all this stuff yes i found it
i hope that this is not going to cause
a disaster here
so this is a great book if you want to
learn
um latin my if you want to learn a
language by yourself i would definitely
uh i would definitely stay away from
traditional approaches which make it
very
learning latin very boring this is
amazing just to give you an idea how
this works
it's just like learning learning
a language through input comprehensible
input so
if you read the stuff you can literally
learn to it's a little bit unfocused
maybe from here you can
it's because of the camera but basically
how this works is that you read a text
and
you learn through context you learn from
images and
the whole thing is built upon
this is predicated upon this principle
that you learn by
following a story it's familiar
so it's a story of a roman family and
they show you they expand the
you know the the view into the the roman
world and the same
is for greek so there are materials and
people right now
who are pushing towards a
non-traditional approach approach and i
uh i
highly recommend this uh this approach
you can you can find a lot of
information about that
in the um in an article that i wrote
about how to learn
ancient languages and kevin can provide
uh the you know feedback
sorry can provide a link to the
to the article and you can find a lot of
information a lot of links to what i'm
talking about
so uh
let me see here let me go down if
there's any questions
valesca at what point in learning a new
language can you start learning another
it it depends on you it depends on what
language you want to learn it depends on
a number of factors i would say if
you're learning a language
and you want to learn another one my
suggestion would be learn a language
well
and by well i mean at least reach a
conversational level
so to speak and then and then you can
start another one but do not make the
mistake of forgetting about the previous
one so learning another language does
not mean
that you're going to forget about the
one you've you've been learning you
don't jump from one to the other which
is a very common mistake
unless you want to just dabble with a
lot of languages that's totally fine
but if you're serious about building a
collection of you know building skills
in multiple languages once you learn a
language
and you reach a certain point then if
you want to learn another one
don't forget that you have to maintain
the other one it's just like having kids
you know you're having the newborn needs
a lot of attention the other one
could get jealous if you don't attend to
the other kid and the more kids you have
the messier is going to be
and also if you're learning a new
language as i said before that is very
similar to the one you're learning
if you're if you learn a language just a
little bit
or you do not even reach conversational
level in a language then they're going
to
there's going to be a huge conflict
between the two if say you're an
american
you're a native english speaker you're
learning spanish and after three months
you don't
you still you know speak bits and bobs
of of spanish and you want to learn
italian on top of that then it's going
to be a mess so
you know i i think you should at least
get a solid
let's say solid you should get solid
skills conversational skills at least
in a language i don't want to get to at
least a b1 or b2
and then move on to the next one this is
what i would do but then whatever faults
you're both as they say so
so how would you learn a language that
has a different alphabet for example
chinese
well i always use the same method
so i always use a bi-directional
translation method in which i
translate i have a you know i have
let me see if i can find chinese i have
a text you know this is chinese so you
have a text in chinese
but the chinese and any good language
learning resource has a transliteration
so you can actually see
how you know you see the latin letters i
always rely on
latin letters and i focus on the meaning
of of
of the language and i translate first
into italian
into a google doc and then a few days
later into chinese
at the beginning i just typed the
transliteration and then
after a few weeks i start typing
directly in the characters you can
download a keyboard
if you have a mac or you have a pc it's
very easy to download a keyboard
and start typing you know typing if you
type the
latin letters then the the system will
transform latin letters into
characters i wouldn't mind i wouldn't
recommend
you folk that you focus only on
characters focus on the language
and then you can learn characters on the
go asimil provides
it's not i can't find it here but asimil
and other courses provide specifically
other
resources that are you know very
specific for writing
as well for writing for for handwriting
uh and this goes for japanese as well
but i think you should focus on the
language more than anything then
you know nowadays we have amazing
resources
to get any text in chinese or japanese
and make it immediately comprehensible
both in terms of writing and in terms of
meaning so
i think the approach they have is very
much the same it's just that the tools
that i use are slightly different
so robinson i'm really desperate to know
about speaking with yourself more
exactly the method you use could you
give it at least one piece of advice
for this yes my piece of advice my piece
of advice would be
to to make it systematic to
maybe attach it to your if you have a
learning session every day
in the morning or at night just make
sure that five minutes
at the end of the session or five
minutes before the session
you just use some fragments and pieces
of words
that maybe you have collected somewhere
from previous
resources or previous conversations from
movies
and you try to form you know short
stories with them so just to give you
a glimpse of what i do uh i don't have a
conversation in a vacuum i always
use reuse pieces of fragments of
conversations
that i get from other uh you know
resources or other experiences like i'm
speaking with my tutor and then i
simulate i
i pretend that i'm speaking to someone
again um
and this works really well for me so
luca any recommended books for learning
polish tj tj
i would say asimu i know i'm i'm you
know
i sound a little bit like um i always
say astral but i think asimo is a great
resource for learning european languages
and then i would definitely use
real polish if you go or write
realpolish.ppl
it's an amazing resource for beginners
asimo
and that resource learning for learn
real polish
they're just great you can start with
those ones and it's going to keep you
busy for like six months or more and
then you have
a lot of more amazing resources if you
go to lucamparello.com
if you go to the page the resource page
you can find all the stuff for polish
for both beginners and intermediate
learners
marie how does being multilingual affect
your way of thinking and your way of
life
my way of thinking it affects my way of
thinking my way of life in the sense
that
it opened new worlds for me i recently
watched a very interesting book a movie
well movie
uh youtube video two youtube videos
talking about arrival
i don't know if you've ever heard of the
movie uh a rival
by gilnev 2016 and this movie explores a
possibility
there's a very famous um uh
you know idea in linguistics according
to which
um language defines influences thought
or defines thought even
i think it's a uh gurf the saphir course
hypothesis
hypothesis or something on those lines
and i don't believe in that meaning i
don't believe that language defines
thought and i believe more than
you know thought defines language we
have some things that we can't really
verbalize
so they don't you don't need a language
to express those
but i do believe that language learning
has the indirect
uh consequence of opening up new worlds
opening up like
my world the way i see the world is is i
think i believe
a little bit different than the the
average person because
through languages i have learned a big
lesson that we're all
you know uh we all are we are all human
beings as tried as it may seem
there's a lot of differences but there's
more similarities than
different the differences so my way of
seeing life has changed a lot the way i
travel but also
it has very practical consequences one
of which is that i can
work i can i have the job of my dreams
which is working with languages
and you know my way of life is different
because i
i'm italian i live in rome but i spend i
have a very
unconventional life here in rome i don't
spend a lot of time with italians i
tend to spend a lot of time um i feel
really in the literal sense of the world
as
a citizen of the world so my way of
thinking my way of life
are international and uh and i'm glad
i'm very glad that i i can do that and i
you know
more and more i understand the the
beautiful variety of the world
the diversity and and i enjoyed more and
more and when this pandemic damn
pandemic is over
i will be able to enjoy it even more
traveling and exploring even more
physically traveling
to distant countries and enjoying the
morality
diversity and beauty of foreign
languages and cultures
so um let me see
thank you so much robinson you're most
welcome let me see there's a lot of
questions here
i don't want to get lost so um
andrea benavidez i look i'm a language
lover spanish is my native language
and i've learned three other languages
from scratch i'm from venice
venezuela and i want to become a
language coach to help others
any tips i've been receiving a lot
a lot of questions recently a lot of
private questions asking me if i can
train them to become language coaches
and i've been thinking about this i've
been thinking that um
you know it would be great to train
other trainers and i'm probably going to
do that
next year but with this premise i would
say that if you want to become a
language coach
i would say that you have to get
experience the most important thing is
experience when i started learning as
a language coach i didn't have any
experience 10 years ago
and i just threw myself at it you know i
said well just
just let's do it and you learn by doing
more than anything you can read all the
books in the world there are some books
of our language coach or being a coach
in general
david rock for example he's a great guy
if you ever heard of david brock he
wrote
your brain at work maybe kevin you can
you can um
you can add a link and he also wrote
about coaching
and i think that's great reading about
coaching and how
the best coaches act and what they do
but most of all if you want to become a
language coach you should
actually start working with you know
with with people like hey
maybe you can even start by giving
lessons lessons for free at the
beginning
and you know you you can get practice
you know and practice helping people as
a coach one of the most important things
you have to do is to learn to ask
questions you have to remember that
everyone is different
so uh for every student that i have i
more or less i i can have a strategy in
mind because i have a lot of experience
but everyone is different
so i keep i ask questions you wanna know
you wanna
you wanna know the story a language
learning a language is a story it's a
story of your life so
when it comes to understanding what a
person needs in order to improve their
language skills you have to understand
where they come from
and asking what level they're at is not
a really relevant question you
ask what have you done to do this so one
of the questions i always start with is
what have you done when it comes to
reading what have you done when it comes
to writing
what have you done when it comes to
speaking and
when the students tell me their story i
understand a lot about the gaps
what you know their strengths and
weaknesses and so on and so forth so
just to give you a couple of pieces of
advice get practice even for free
doesn't matter just
find someone you can help and then start
asking
questions and then you you can start
experimenting finding reason
you know you have to motivate the person
for sure but you can also give links you
can
start you know experiment with that
person now i cannot go in
very much in depth with this but um it
this is this has been my experience as a
coaches learning to ask questions
and uh experiment and you will learn
you know you will learn pretty quickly
um
it's one of the best things in the world
to be able to help others and see
how they thrive once they follow your
advice
you know that and your guidance i i
think the language coach is one of the
the coolest the coolest jobs in the
world
so let me see uh what's your opinion
about link olga
olga yes this is i'll get you asked a
question before if i'm not right if i'm
not wrong
i like it i like i love link i
i just uh just to give you an idea
i hope you can see it this is the amount
of stuff
that i've printed i can show this
guys do not get scared so this is
i think you can see it here you can see
how much i work on a piece of paper this
is like a
um i got it from link so i download
every single well i used to download
this is for chinese when i was learning
chinese
i loved link i used link to learn
chinese i got like
this is heavy guys it's just like 100
podcasts from there and i work
through thoroughly um so i
i think i think link is is is fantastic
but it's how you use it it makes a
difference so remember that i think
link and is is a great resource if you
learn how to use it then bingo
bruno bruno ferreira what about duolingo
i have never used duolingo
and but i um i wouldn't
i've never felt the necessity of using
it if you want to play around a little
bit that's that's okay
maybe on you know the the
the cherry on top so to speak uh i would
use it as a cherry on top you want to
spend five minutes uh
you know playing around that's fine but
i think the bulk of your learning should
come
elsewhere not from duolingo i'm not a
big fan of apps if i got to tell you the
truth but if you keep you motivated if
you want to use it for five minutes a
day
you know cherry on top or whatever i
remember it was the icing on the cake
and the cherry on top
and then and you know that's great uh
what language you want to learn next
asks daniela
i don't know it's between turkish hebrew
and arabic
we'll see no i'm sorry serbian
that's serbian it's gonna happen in
september hopefully so serbian first and
then one of these three languages
so uh yarno i think it's
grenier i'm upper b1 i'm upper b1 in
russian what are the
resources you recommend to reach fluency
in russian please check my website
i would say russian podcast for sure e
you can if you if you go to the website
you you will see it
and uh martial is a nice guy i met him a
couple of times he's he's doing a great
job with russian progress
his website is great his um videos are
on and off i i watch them and it's
fantastic stuff
it's for for learners he talks about
language learning you can find all the
resources
in the in the russian session on my
website so
check that so i'm kind of curious
christian santa asks how many languages
do you speak and how do you keep
motivated well depending on how you
define speak obviously i've been
learning 14 languages
and i believe that i can manage you know
at the
the drop of a hat as they say if i had
to uh
you know have a conversation right now
with native speakers
i think i would manage in at least uh 10
languages if not 12. there's a couple of
them that are kind of rusty
um but i would say to 10 languages uh
then the definition of you know fluency
what does it mean to speak a language
fluently
uh well that's that's uh that's a
different matter but i would say that i
speak
you know definition of speak being able
to communicate comfortably at least in
10 languages
so sun is going down i think you can
change you can see that
the light change
so batista how would you suggest to
better explore
spontaneous random talk on the streets
on a country where
you're learning their native language
things bando goes
well i would say get to know some people
get to know some people go if
now the pandemic is a little bit
difficult but i would if i were you i
would
go to places where people for example
they gathered to
speak to learn languages in france you
used to go to this cafe
where you got to know a lot of
foreigners and french wanting to
exchange languages and once you get to
know these people then you can make
friends with them and spend a lot of
time with them
i think it's big talking with people on
the street is okay but it's not a very
let's say deep interaction you can learn
to say
some things to greet people that are
very like that are kind of recurring but
in order to have
i think to have to develop your language
skills even on the street even
just talking with people interacting
with people i would you're better off
actually getting to know someone and
spending time with them and then they
can introduce you to some other people
and that's how you expand your
uh you know your language skills in
general um
so how do you get fluent in language i
think i i
answered that numerous times and it's
kind of
a you know a lengthy answer um
what languages do you teach asks roxanna
kasim begola i think that's your last
name i
do not exactly teach languages but i
have lesson i train people to learn
languages
i can you know i don't i don't really
teach by i have
in my classes you also have advanced
conversation skills so depending on what
people
ask they either learn a language from
scratch or
which is one of the the requests that i
get most of the time is that look i'm a
little bit lost i want to get to c1
uh you know they there's a lot of people
who want to improve their language
skills they already speak fluently but
they want to speak well
like really well that's a different
matter then we engage
in conversations in these specific
languages but to answer your question
i i i work i use
english italian french spanish german
i use dutch russian polish these are the
nine languages they use in all
combinations like
a french wanted to learn russian a
russian guy or a girl wanting to learn
french or english an american
wanted to learn italian and it's how he
wanted to learn english tie-ins wanting
to learn german
germans wanting to learn spanish or
italian so i have all
combinations and i get to use between
six and nine languages at work so i
speak in these languages
either to explain the nuts and bolts of
language learning dynamics and mechanics
whatever you want to call them
and then i also have specific classes
that are designed to
have my students improve their skills so
i also get to practice these languages
by helping others
so leandro nowadays the app most used by
polygons is
speakly have you used it i think they
contacted me i think i received a
message recently but
i don't think i've ever used them to
tell you the truth uh not yet
at least so um
let me see have you ever been called a
perfectionist brandon
nope i i i don't think so i
i'm not a perfect i mean i'm a
perfectionist in the sense that i would
like to perfect
my languages or my accent or my way of
living etc
i strive for excellence but i don't
strive for perfection because perfection
is just an illusion
it's a figment of your mind so to speak
it doesn't
it it just lives in our heads but it's
not something we can
achieve i can't you and i think the
perfectionism syndrome
actually gets in the way i've learned to
let go i've learned that
it's better to try to do something like
today's messy
beginning than not to try to do
something and being scared about it like
every time we try to do something new
there's always a little bit of
uncertainty
i i believe i really like saying that
any form of growth entails a little bit
of discomfort
so um like even writing a book you know
i was talking about it i
i think i got blocked when it when the
some
five years ago thinking am i good enough
to write a book i think i
you know you're always thinking okay the
book should be perfect but the reality
is
getting a book out you're not getting a
course out getting anything out
it it's not going to be perfect at the
beginning and it's never going to be
perfect
it's better to get something good and
then perfect it with time rather than
not getting anything because you're a
perfectionist
so to answer your question maybe someone
has called me a perfectionist but i
don't consider myself one and i don't
consider that perfection it
should be should be the goal in anything
in life
um at least life luca we love you so
much
uh keep up think thanks a lot uh good
greetings from kazakhstan
salam salem uh i love you guys too as
well
so um can you tell me if you have any
thoughts on the
10k challenge it involves reading 10 000
pages of books
in your tl um i
i haven't heard of this 10k challenge to
tell you the truth
so i can't tell much about it but i can
tell you one thing i think you should
read
a lot you should get into the habit of
reading whatever whatever
whatever you have whatever you want to
read whatever interests you
just read you know that can change your
life if you do it for a long time even
if it's just a couple of pages a day
it's it's really gonna make a difference
so i'm sorry to disappoint you i don't
know much about this 10
000 you know pages challenge
but um i would say uh get into the habit
of reading
you know that's the most important thing
i would do
mike how do you motivate yourself to
keep on learning a language it's a very
interesting question and i think it's a
really
very relevant one this is what i do
every single day
in the back of my mind i have learned to
visualize myself using this language
there's not a
not a single day goes by without me
thinking about
how cool it's going to be to be speaking
greek in greece
that that is what you know drives drives
me compels me pushes me
towards uh learning when even you know
when
when it's difficult when uh when you you
know
when you find obstacles in the back of
my mind there's always this
this thing of the the beauty of speaking
a foreign language that i've lived
before and that's what pushes me forward
i think that what makes me tick is the
possibility of
not only expanding my world but also
getting in contact with other worlds and
that
has happened multiple times and this is
happening with greek it's happening with
hungarian if you want to motivate
yourself
if you're low on motivation you have to
find someone that
you know ignites this desire again in my
case for example one thing that i did to
get even more motivated if if it was
necessary because the truth is i'm
already very motivated is to
find a program a language school
in in greece this this summer so that i
know that i'm going to go to greece you
know
corona mr corona allowing and that
in and of itself motivates me a lot to
keep going with greek
with learning greek so for me what
really motivates me is the possibility
of
speaking and using the language in
country or with people in general
this is what makes me tick this is what
compels me what drives me what what what
pushes me to learn
every single day is the contact with
other worlds be it
through people or through movies through
books and what have you
so uh let's see
uh we still have five minutes guys so
kevin answer for me luca doesn't use
flash cards or anki he's
he's right i don't use flash cards and i
don't use anki but i do use a space
based
space repetition system because you need
to repeat uh
you need to review words if you want
them to stuck
to your long-term memory to get stuck in
your long-term memory
um so let's see
uh higher channel fuel with my love for
languages vivian
because of you improving my english
portuguese i'm learning romanian
thanks for your help when will you start
learning less known
when would you start learning less known
languages
if you're asking whether i'm going to
start learning less known languages
i i don't learn a language because it's
known or less known or exotic or
non-exotic i learn a language because
as i said before it helps me um
live a better life so if i um
you know say went to new zealand and
fell in love with the maori
culture and then i would learn maori
even if it's spoken by i don't know
three thousand four thousand ten
thousand
one million people so i learned
languages based on my experiences my
life
my life that's what that's if if this
question was was addressed to me
directly when i'm gonna learn
uh exotic languages it depends i always
say i don't learn languages as languages
i don't choose languages
languages choose me um
michael what's your take on shadowing as
a way to practice pronunciation i have a
couple of videos about uh not shadowing
but how i
how i improve my pronunciation what i do
with a pencil and a pen
i have a system to visualize the the
intonation patterns of a language and
then
to repeat these patterns i have nothing
against shadowing i think it's a good
resource
if it's a good technique if you like
doing that by all means do that
it's a very good way of articulating um
sounds but as i uh you know practicing
the sound patterns of the language but i
think it's
always important to develop some sort of
awareness when it comes to
how the sound patterns work if you have
that little bit of awareness
on top of shadowing then you know
even better so last couple of questions
um sorry guys again not to answer every
single one it's impossible i wish you
could do that maybe one day we can do a
marathon a 48 hour marathon
but unfortunately for now it's not
possible
so um do you learn one or multiple
languages per day
pablo normally one or a maximum two or
thirty minutes it might surprise you i
don't spend
a lot of time learning languages
actively but i do spend a lot of time
using
the languages that i know in my daily
life so that's the difference so on a
on a daily basis i can spend 30 to 45
minutes say learning greek
and or hungarian for example and then a
couple of days
of the week danish but then i also speak
four five
six languages on a daily basis so i use
them more than learn them it's a
different phase when you start using a
language
and you don't learn the language
actually anymore that's a completely
different stage
so uh what was the most
challenging european language you
learned german dude versus japan
interesting name um i think romanian and
you know why because
i as i said it before even if it's easy
it's not difficult
it's really close language i was not
interested i
i didn't have a compelling reason to
learn so i found that difficult i found
it difficult to continue in general
that's that's what
you know some it was a subjective factor
was a personal reason why i found it
difficult but
objectively if you're asking what
language is objectively
what was the the most objectively
difficult for me
i would say russian i would say russian
because it was the first time that i
learned a slavic language
and asked verb aspects and cases
and cyrillic and a number of other
things
made it kind of difficult to learn
russian in the very beginning plus
other technical difficulties i had in
downloading and using the keyboard and
some other tools that made it
difficult at the beginning but i would
say that
that was the most difficult language i
think polish is more or less the same
diff
i i would say is as difficult as russian
but when i started learning
polish i already spoke fluent russian so
it was less
difficult and it would have been the
other way around if i had
started learning polish first
um so do you have any advice for
learning perfective imperfective form
in russian i think i'll make a video
about that it's a very interesting
question
um i don't think i have made a video
about that specifically but i have made
a video about learning
verbs so if you want to check that out
kevin maybe you can provide the the link
i
made a video about learning words i'm
sorry learning verbs in general and you
can find some very valuable
pieces of advice that you can apply to
learning russian verbs and i think i
have a couple of examples for russian as
well
in there and you can as always also read
and or listen to the corresponding
um you know article that i wrote about
that because every
at least over the last two years we have
a video and we also have the
corresponding article
and the audio uh you know about a
specific
uh aspect of language running in general
okay guys i think that's this is it uh
i know you're asking uh more questions
there but then we have to
we have to go the next i think the next
streaming we promise first that we won't
have technical problems at least we're
going to try
to do our best the next one is going to
be in a month
so normally it should be the last sunday
of the month and i think we're going to
do one more
in english and then buckle up because
we're going to start doing
this in multiple languages well multiple
languages in
first in spanish this is going to be the
the second language we're going to
explore and then let's see how this goes
obviously
i know that not all of you
you know speak spanish but i'm pretty
sure you have we have here a lot of
native
spanish speakers and i'm pretty sure we
also have
a lot of people who speak spanish as a
second language
in mind that for those who want to
participate in the la in the next
q a i speak spanish i have a couple of
videos on youtube speaking spanish in
in real life i speak spanish fast
spanish from spain
but i will try to speak hablar espanol
lentamente claramente so that also
people who
um you know speak spanish at a b1 level
let's say they can enjoy
hopefully this q a
uh and um isa asks
i i'm sorry that this is a little bit
late about how to set
quantifiable language goals this is a
great um
it's a great question uh one book about
that is measure
what matters i don't know if you ever
heard about that but i think
this measure what matters book would
help you
in that as well but i really like that
that question
um is uh i think i have another
video that i made about that uh it's
about if you if you look for if you
write goals
i think you should find out how to
measure language goals or something
along those lines
and there's a youtube video that i made
on
the rooftop here and also the
corresponding article so check
that that one out but i'll keep that in
mind i might make another video about
that because it's a very interesting and
important question okay guys
so this is
it thank you very much for coming and
for being
patient for having the patience of
waiting 20 minutes
um and hopefully the next one is going
to be a little bit smoother
smoother and i wanted to
thank you again for all the wonderful
questions that you're asking and all the
enthusiasm
300 of you come regularly if not even
more so this
is really exciting and it makes me
happy and makes my my my team uh very
proud and happy that we can
help you in any way we can and um
and this is it have a fantastic sunday
have a fantastic
month and i'll see you guys in a month
again
the next one is going to be in english
but then we're going to start doing
this in spanish and then let's see
what other language we're going to be
doing this in
thank you guys you guys are fantastic
and i'll see you
in a month bye bye ciao
you